Speaker 1: I have the most outrageous clip
for you from this judge Bruce Schroeder,
Schreuder Schrader. Everybody tells me a different
every time I pronounce it. One way I get an email
saying it's the other one. So I'll say Schrader
kind of a middle middle ground on them in the
Kyle Rittenhouse trial, talking about when he had
a black in his jury. It's, you know, there's there
are things about this guy that we could say are
relevant to the case substantively that we are
concerned with. And there's things about this guy
that just make him seem kind of like a wacky guy.
And what this is about is the fact that on the
day that the jury started deliberating and as of
this moment, the jury continues to deliberate
into day three about the five charges against
Kyle Rittenhouse, the judge. You had a pool of
18 jurors and they all all watched all of the
testimony and looked at all of the evidence, but
only 12 actually participate in the deliberations.
So on the first day of deliberations, they had
to choose six of the 18 to serve as alternates,
meaning they stay at the courthouse day after day
without deliberating. In case anything happens to
the 12 jurors that are actually taking part in
the deliberation. The way they selected the six
to come out is they had a tumbler almost like
if you had like a lottery and they tumbled the
names in pieces of paper with the juror numbers
on them, and they actually had Kyle Rittenhouse
reach in and select the six people that would
be removed from the 18. And a lot of people in
the media thought that was weird. Why it's almost
like a game show. Why is Kyle Rittenhouse himself
doing it? And the judge has a perfectly reasonable
explanation, which is there have been times in the
past where when it wasn't when, when we were doing
it, when it was the clerk, for example, doing it,
you would have an outcome that raised eyebrows
like, for example, the one black potential juror
being the one that is removed. And it's like, Oh
my goodness, it looks like racial. So the judge
explains that in order to prevent that, he
says, well, we'll just let the defendant do
it so that we can't be accused of hand picking
juries based on race or any other features. But
he, bizarrely in telling the story, says that
when they did this once, what came up was a black,
the black, and it just is so odd to hear him
talk this way, take a look at this person.
Speaker 5: It was a big case I think
was a murder case, but I'm not sure.
And there were there was a black defendant and
there were 13 jurors, one of whom was black.
And when the clerk, the clerk, the government
official, drew the name or the tumbler,
it was a black, the black.
Speaker 1: It was a black
and it was the black, only black.
Speaker 5: There was nothing wrong
with it. It was all OK. But what did they talk
about? Optics nowadays is that the word for
things that was a bad optic. I thought, yeah.
Speaker 1: Also, bad optics is referring to
it was a black, a black.
Speaker 5: I think people
feel better when they have control.
Speaker 1: Yeah. This is completely
reasonable. It's what the substance is completely
reasonable. I'm not saying this guy is a racist or
the racist, but the way in which he talks about
a black and the black makes makes me cringe.
It really does. And this is just again, he's
just a very there's two sides to this guy.
He seems like a very quirky, strange guy singing
songs during the trial, doing jeopardy questions
with people in the crowd freaking out and yelling
at the cameras about coverage on telly. You know,
all these just very, very strange things. And
then there are also the alleged biases that are
being ascribed to the judge when it comes to
evidence standards, depending on whether the
evidence is presented by the prosecution or by the
defense. His evaluation of different aspects of
the trial and questions to witnesses speculative
questions, etc.. OK, that's that's a whole other
thing. But what a wacky guy. I am very much
looking forward to when this trial is done and
we can move on from it. And we are standing
by for the verdict. Literally, as we speak,
we may be minutes from the verdict. We may be
hours could be days still to go. We will see.